MDR wissen
die großen Fragen in 10 Minuten
der Podcast der die Welt erklärt
[Musik]
würden sie von sich behaupten dass sie
böse sind wahrscheinlich eher nicht
grundsätzlich liegt es in uns gut sein
zu wollen und trotzdem wird es den einen
oder anderen Nachbarn geben der
möglicherweise behauptet wir sein böse
Gut und Böse sind also moralische
Kategorien zum einen und sie sind
abhängig vom Standpunkt von der
Sichtweise
das ist aber nur eine Seite der Medaille
hier soll es auch um das wirklich böse
das unstrittig böse gehen und die Frage
warum gibt es Menschen die richtig böse
sind Adolf Hitler zum Beispiel oder KZ
auf sehr Serienmörder vergewaltigen
einer der tief ins Schwarz der Seele
geblickt hat ist der österreichische
Psychiater Reinhard Haller als
forensisch psychiatrischer Gutachter hat
er die bösen der bösen getroffen den
Sexualmörder Jack Unterweger den
NS-Euthanasie Arzt Heinrich Grass und
den briefbombenattentäter Franz Fuchs um
nur einige zu nennen
böse aber ist in der Psychologie keine
Diagnose böse Menschen gibt es dort
nicht das was für unser meisten das Böse
verkörpert wird in der Psychologie mit
der Persönlichkeitsstörung bösartiger
oder malignal Narzissmus beschrieben
erklärt Reinhard Haller dieses Syndrom
des bösartigen Narzissmus hat man bei 98
Prozent der amerikanischen Serienkiller
nachweisen können und wir können diese
Persönlichkeitsstruktur letztlich auch
beschreiben bei einem großen desputen
der Menschheit von Ivan dem
schrecklichen von Kaiser Nero bis Adolf
Hitler zu josefstalin oder zu Paul
Butter darauf hat man das immer
feststellen können die sind nicht
geisteskrank sondern sie sind bösartige
Narzissten und das ist das was
psychologisch das Böse am meisten
verkörpert
die Ursache des Bösen hat also eine
Diagnose hätte also eine
Abrechnungsnummer auf dem Krankenschein
bösartige Narzissten lassen sich so
beschreiben sie leben ihren Selbstwert
auf Kosten anderer aus das bedeutet sie
fühlen sich eigentlich minderwertig um
das zu ändern und unterdrücken und
quälen sie andere Menschen erklärt
Haller diese Menschen haben ein hohes
Maß an Sadismus sondern durchaus auch
sexuelleismus der sich aber auch in der
Form des quellensandter besonders
Aufsehen kann sie sind die sozial das
heißt sie halten sich an keine Regeln
die Gesetze der Moral der Ethik der
Strafrechtes gelten für sie nicht sie
schaffen sich ihre eigenen Gesetze in
denen sie im Mittelpunkt stehen und in
denen sie überleben und tut und
Schicksal anderen Menschen bestimmen und
sie sind schließlich auch noch in einem
hohen Maße misstrauisch das heißt sie
sind in jedem Mitmenschen einen Feind
den es zu bekämpfen gibt
solche wirklich bösen Menschen gibt es
sehr sehr wenige Psychologe aller
beziffert sie auf 0,01 Prozent das
Problem beginnt dann wenn solche
Narzissten viel Macht bekommen und dann
gar einen Krieg anzetteln können Krieg
es nämlich der Vater des Bösen sagt
Haller auf einer kalten kognitiven Ebene
werden die Gegner entmenschlicht
Mitgefühl wird abgestellt im Krieg wird
gefoltert und getötet hier zeigt sich
das Böse von seiner schlimmsten Seite
aber selbst dann springt einem das Böse
nicht frontal ins Gesicht man sieht
immer nur die brutalen Verbrechen die
aber immer oder meist mit Heeren Motiven
guten Absichten und Visionen begründet
werden denn selbst die bösen wollen sich
selten eingestehen dass sie wirklich
böse sind
keine Armee zieht in einen Krieg in dem
Selbstverständnis der böse zu sein das
sind immer die anderen
Kreuzzüge der Zweite Weltkrieg und auch
jetzt der russische invasionskrieg alle
Aggressoren sehen sich auf der guten
Seite der Weltgeschichte als Befreier
als Opfer als Recher der Philosoph Jörg
Noller hier spielt wiederum die
Täuschung eine große Rolle die
Selbsttäuschung man glaubt wenn man böse
handelt häufig man tue das Gute aber
täuscht dich darüber und tut eigentlich
das Böse und das macht das Böse so
gefährlich weil diejenigen die böse
Handeln eigentlich häufig glauben sie
täten das Gute und selbst zu täuschen
darin sind wir Menschen wirklich gut
glauben wir heute nicht alle wir hätten
im Zweiten Weltkrieg Juden versteckt
oder wären in den Widerstand gegangen
das Böse kann sich sehr schnell im
Alltag verstecken zum normalen werden
zur Pflichterfüllung Hannah Arendt hat
in diesem Zusammenhang den Begriff die
Banalität des Bösen geprägt der Begriff
tauchte ursprünglich in ihrem
prozessbericht auf über den deutschen
ss-obersturmbandführer Adolf Eichmann
der war mitverantwortlich für die
Ermordung von rund 6 Millionen Juden
eindeutig ein durch und durch böser
Mensch oder Hannah Arendt beschrieb ihn
als banal als eine Person der man beim
besten Willen keine dämonische Tiefe
abgewinnen könne das erklärt Philosoph
Noller etwas näher die Banalität des
Bösen meint jetzt nicht das Adolf
Eichmann banal war dass seine Taten
banal warten sondern vielmehr das Adolf
Eichmann und auch andere Funktionären
dieser Zeit sich nur den Anschein der
Banalität gegeben haben sie haben sich
nur als kleines Rädchen im Getriebes
stilisiert dass doch eigentlich gar
keine Verantwortung zu übernehmen hat
und diesen Begriff finde ich deswegen so
spannend weil er doch recht schillernd
ist er sollte nicht so verstanden werden
dass das Böse banal ist ganz im
Gegenteil das Böse verleiht sich den
Anschein der Banalität und deswegen
täuscht uns auch das moderne böse so
häufig weil wir glauben dass wir gar
nicht verantwortlich sein weil wir doch
nur kleine Rädchen im Getriebe sind
wechseln wir also die Perspektive um gut
zu sein müssen wir demnach Verantwortung
tragen es reicht eben nicht zu sagen es
wurde von mir verlangt philosophisch
betrachtet hängt diese Verantwortung
damit zusammen dass wir uns ja auch
anders entscheiden können denn wir haben
ja nicht nur die Möglichkeit Böses zu
tun sondern eben auch gutes der Mensch
hat in sich als freies Wesen immer
Tendenzen zum Guten wie zum Bösen
Immanuel Kant spricht von einem Hang zum
Bösen der jedem Menschen mitgegeben ist
aber auch von einer Anlage zum Guten die
auch jeder Mensch als Mensch als freies
Wesen hat das heißt wir haben in uns
gewisse Neigungen nicht das Gute zu tun
also uns selbst über die Interessen der
anderen zu stellen unser eigenes Ding zu
drehen das ist so ein bisschen der Hang
zum Bösen wir haben aber auch eine
Anlage zum Guten nämlich mit anderen zu
kooperieren anderen etwas zu gönnen mit
anderen zu kommunizieren auf eine
konstruktive Weise beide sind
Grundtendenzen unsere Existenz sie
machen uns als Menschen aus als
freiwesen
der Mensch ist somit von Natur aus weder
gut noch böse er ist immer beides und
kann immer beides sein Menschen per se
als gut oder böse zu beschreiben wäre
immer eine Verkürzung sagt die
evangelische Theologin und Philosoph in
Petra Bahr man sollte immer
unterscheiden zwischen einem Menschen
und seiner Tat seinem Werk wie sie es
nennt wenn man sagt dieser
Mensch eigentlich nur dieser Mensch hat
sich in eine ganz fürchterliche
Weltsicht verstrickt oder plant oder hat
sie gar durchgesetzt eine böse Tat aber
die Unterscheidung von Personen und Werk
zieht sich in den biblischen Traditionen
bis hin zum Schlimmsten also bis hin
etwa zu Judas dem Verräter da gibt es
große Abhandlungen schon im Mittelalter
wieso Gott Judas trotzdem
liebt aber diese fürchterliche Tat des
liebesverrats verachtet
auch der Philosoph Jürgen Noller ist der
Meinung charakterisieren wir einen
Menschen als böse nehmen wir ihm die
Freiheit sich wieder zum Guten zu
entwickeln es kann also durchaus böse
von uns sein andere Menschen böse zu
nennen für Hitler und Stalin ist die
Nummer vielleicht gelaufen aber für die
meisten anderen gibt es durchaus Wege
zurück das Christentum schlägt
voreinander zu vergeben derjenige der
böse gehandelt hat muss um Vergebung
bitten genauso wichtig ist dann der
Person auch zu vergeben
schließlich geht es bei einer bösen Tat
am Ende immer auch um die Opfer wie geht
es Ihnen damit machen nicht ihre
Reaktionen oder ihre Gefühle die böse
Tat am Ende erst böse
der entscheidende Punkt ist immer die
Empathie sich in andere
hineinzuversetzen eine Fähigkeit die
Psychopathen zum Beispiel fehlt
Philosoph Jörg Nöller schlägt vor immer
eine Außenperspektive zuzulassen man
kann häufig im Bösen nicht alleine
entscheiden ob es jetzt böse ist sondern
man sollte sich öffnen in seinen
Handlungen für die Urteile von anderen
Menschen das heißt man braucht immer
eine Außenperspektive und kann sehr
schlecht selbst beurteilen ob das was
man tut eigentlich gut oder böse ist das
heißt man muss bereit sein sich immer
auch von außen korrigieren zu lassen
wenn ich also stur mein Ding durchziehe
rücksichtslos über Leichen gehe mein
wohl vor dass der anderen Stelle dann
kann ich davon ausgehen dass da gerade
eine Menge passiert
das als böse wahrgenommen wird lasse ich
andere Meinungen zu und kooperiere dann
wird die Wahrnehmung von dem was ich tue
und wer ich bin eine andere sein ein
Balanceakt ohne Schafe Grenzen
wahrscheinlich haben wir alle einen
inneren Kompass was gut und was böse ist
das vermutet zumindest Psychologe
Reinhard Haller er geht von einem
inneren moralinstinkt aus manchmal setzt
er eben ganz kurz aus wenn wir im Rausch
handeln oder im Affekt denn genau dann
passieren die meisten bösen Taten die
Rede ist von zwischenmenschlichen
Konflikten in den eigenen vier Wänden
also schaukelt sich gegenseitig empor
oft so ist dann tatsächlich auch den
Themen die Wirkung des Alkohols mit dem
Spiel und am Höhepunkt dieser
emotionalen Kaskade ergreifte Täter zu
der Waffe die man hier ist und dann
verübte diese affektive tat er ist
gleichsam blind vor Wut wenn kann sich
selbst nicht mehr kontrollieren und dann
kommt das böse zum Durchbruch
es gibt Menschen die dafür
prädestinierter sind als andere
Psychologen können bestimmte
Risikofaktoren ausmachen allen voran die
Erziehung natürlich der abwesende Vater
die vernachlässigende lieblose Mutter
sind solche Stereotype die psychologisch
aber durchaus von Bedeutung sind wer als
Kind missbraucht wurde neigt statistisch
eher dazu später andere zu missbrauchen
vortrefflich kann man darüber
diskutieren ob der Körper nicht böses
vorgibt das Killer gehen zum Beispiel
das straftäterhirn hatte zum Beispiel
ein Hirntumor dafür gesorgt dass Charles
widmen
1966 17 Menschen an der Universität in
Osten erschossen hatte
[Musik]
immer wieder finden Wissenschaftler
Hinweise auf biologische Ursachen für
aggressives Verhalten schaut man aber
genauer hin wird deutlich so einfach ist
das nicht das Böse das sind immer
mehrere Faktoren und Aggressionen mit
böse gleichzusetzen daraus wird dann
auch kein Schuh Reinhard Haller nennt
Aggression denn auch er das Böse
Potenzial und mit diesem bösen Potenzial
kann man auch richtig tolle Dinge machen
wenn jemand seine Aggressivität also das
Böse Potenzial das darin sich hat in ein
Kulturwerk hineinlegen kann mit der
ganzen Wut deinem Marmorblock
beispielsweise bearbeitet dann entstehen
die herrlichen Kunstwerke die es
überhaupt geben kann dieses Potenzial
umleiten also
so kann man dann auch Krieg spielen ganz
ohne Waffen und Opfer Fußball
beispielsweise enthält alle Elemente
eines Krieges des Vaters des Bösen es
geht immer um das große Geschäft das
marschierende hier ihre auf die Fans die
Gladiatoren die Feldherren das sind die
Trainer das werden es dann Daten
getragen das werden flachgesänge
gesungen es besteht den Kriegsplan und
das Wohl und Wehe unseres Volkes hängt
davon ab ob der Ball im Netz Land der
Doktor nicht er steckt also in uns der
böse trieb dieser Aggressionen nicht nur
zum Fußball spielen sondern auch zum
Überleben wir sind das was wir sind weil
wir uns durchgesetzt haben gegen andere
sei es im Kampf um Nahrung oder bei der
Werbung um unsere Partner um uns
vorzupflanzen das geht nicht anders nur
das organisierte das sadistische das ist
wohl eine besonders natürliche Qualität
des Bösen
[Musik]
die großen Fragen in zehn Minuten
ein MDR Wissen Podcast von und mit
Carsten Möbius
Redaktion Carolin Dörner Produktion
Evelina bardowska